so we're kind of keep trying to keep
track give you some
outline of the scope of the crackdown on
civil liberties
now underway i'm trying to bring you
individuals who suffered
under it here's one a literary agent in
new york works for literary agency in
the city
recently fired not because of what she
said online but because she maintained
accounts on parlor and gab those are
free speech alternatives
to corporate social media the employee's
name is colleen offline and she joins us
tonight colleen i appreciate your coming
on
um so i i really wanted to talk to you
just to make sure i got this right
you were fired not because you said
something outrageous or immoral online
but because you used
specific social media platforms
tucker thank you so much for having me
tonight and thank you for all your hard
work
i really think you hit the nail on the
head in your monologue but yes you are
correct that's
what i got fired for i created a profile
on parlor and i created a profile on gab
i posted the same exact content on
twitter as i posted on those social
media platforms
and that's what i got fired for
what i'm struck by here is you work for
worked for a
literary agency and the basis of course
of literature is
free thinking and so you would think
that a literary agency would be kind of
the last line of defense against this
kind of stalinism what did your bosses
say to you
um actually i it was an email and
pretty succinct that i had created
a profile on parlor and gab and
that because of what they called my
political activities
they had to take swift action and part
ways
since you worked in the literary world
what do you think
the future of literature and art is in a
country where people can be fired for
using
the wrong social media platform
it's chilling tucker it's really
chilling because um uh
it used to be that being silent was
safe on twitter and in american
publishing
but um i feel like this signaled to
those in american publishing that it's
okay to get rid of people
who aren't moderate or who
are moderate who aren't publicly left of
center
they want people left of center and um
so if you were obviously if you were
outwardly conservative
yes you were vilified yes you were
silenced
but being silent used to mean you would
be safe from
those kind of actions now it's you have
to be publicly
on the left otherwise you're out
oh it's really a shocking story i'm
going to save this tape as a kind of
period piece for when we emerge from
this i hope it's soon
good luck colleen thank you for joining
us
thank you tucker